hi in this video
we're going to talk about how map
kindness signaling pathway and its
components
were discovered now whenever we talk
about the map kinase pathway
we very often say the first step is
phosphorylation of the receptor tyrosine
kinase upon ligand binding
followed by binding to a adapter
grb2 and then a gif molecule a guanosine
nucleotide exchange factor molecule sos
binds to that now sos activates
a gtpa's small monomeric gtg protein
known as ras now upon activation of
rash rash allows activation of several
kinases such as
map triple k's now one such example is
raph
now in subsequent state there is a
kinase cascade
and in step wise fashion the kinase
cascade goes on
and ultimately the map kinase is
phosphorylated
which ultimately lead to changes in the
gene expression
and mostly these map kinase pathways are
actually
in are more pronounced in case of
growth signaling pathway which leads to
growth and cell division so the genes
that
are transcribed are mostly important for
growth survival and cell division so
this
was a quick overview of map kinase
pathway
it is very easy to understand from when
the schematic is complete
but imagine that time in early 1970s
when none of these pathway or this
schematic was there
everything was blurry how did
this pathway was drawn this pathway
which only
took two to three minutes for this
overview
it took almost 20 years for this pathway
to be figured out
and in this video we are going to talk
about how that pathway
was discovered how these molecules of
this pathway was discovered
and that particular time
the molecular biology was not so strong
as a result classical genetic
experiments
were beautifully designed to discover
this pathway
in drosophila this components of these
pathways were first
chalked out in drosophila the eyes
just like any other insects is compound
eye
now the compound eye has units known as
omateria and each omateria has
a specific arrangement of photoreceptor
cells in case of flies
there are eight photoreceptor neurons r1
to r8
and r7 is a specific photoreceptor which
is important for uv sensitivity of the
flies
now it has been shown that a specific
receptor tyrosine kinase molecule
known as 7 less and its ligand bride of
7 less is important
for photoreceptor development because in
the mutation
of 7 layers where the receptor tyrosine
kinase is mutated
the photoreceptor development is
abrogated
the r7 photoreceptor neuron is not
properly
developed and it has its behavioral
consequence at as well
now using this assay scientist wanted to
ask that what are the downstream
molecules
which are affecting this pathway because
till now
a broad framework is ready that you have
a signaling molecule the ligand and the
receptor is known
but the downstream pathway molecules are
completely unknown at this stage
but the phenotype is also known which is
ultimately regulating the photoreceptor
development
now what scientists did is a very clever
experiment
they used temperature sensitive mutants
so let me tell you what is temperature
sensitive mutant
so in a non-permissive temperature this
signaling components
would be mutated and no signaling would
take place so at
non permissive temperature the simple
phenotype
is their eye development is perturbed
but in a permissive temperature
the mutation effect won't be visible and
the fly would behave just like a normal
fly
now in an intermediate temperature
there would be just enough amount of
protein
produced such that the photoreceptor
development can take place
a marginal level of signaling activity
would be present
at an intermediate temperature
this is very interesting and very
important because in the intermediate
temperature if you
allow several other mutation in
combination
with the these seven less temperature
sensitive mutant
and then look for in which cases
the development doesn't take place that
means
that with a combinatorial combinatorial
mutation
the particular pathway is blocked or
abrogated
and that exactly scientists did so they
made bunch of combinations for example
with
7 less temperature sensitive mutant they
combined another mutation
a combine another mutation b and so on
so forth
and each cases they looked at
where the eye development of r7
photoreceptor is abrogated
and after a long screening process which
was elegantly developed
they ultimately figure out that the r7
photoreceptor pigment is not properly
developed
in situations let's say for b and let's
say for another molecule
l that tells them that
these molecules this molecule b or these
molecule l might be somehow involved in
these pathway
because if they are not involved in this
pathway
mutating them doesn't matter and the
pathway should have
ultimately lead to photoreceptor
development but as they are important
for somehow
in this pathway their mutation leads to
abrogation in r7 development
now ultimately these
genes that we just
exemplified as b or l turns out to be
grb2 and sos this is how
grb2 and sos are discovered
after that using similar kind of
approach
people found out that which is the
order of these signaling molecules
that means which signaling molecules
come downstream to which signaling
molecule let me give you an example
so what people did they started over
expressing
the same signaling molecules in a
background of 7 less
if it rescues that means
these signaling molecules are acting
downstream to the seven less
mutation right so let me give you a
overall picture such that it is impos
it's possible for you to understand
so let's say we pretty much talked about
the map kinase signaling pathway
right where the signaling components
that we know now that time it was not
known ultimately give rise to specific
gene expressions such as cycling d
or c make now the first and foremost
criteria is the receptor phosphorylation
in the same
mutant the receptor is faulty
that means this the signaling that
should flow via this receptor mediated
pathway
is going to be actually blocked or this
signaling
pathway would be perturbed not happening
right and as a result
the photoreceptor won't be developed but
if you forcefully in this mutant
background
over express grb2 then what would happen
regardless the mutation
the receptor is mutated the signaling
would flow
right and as a result the flux through
the map kinase signaling pathway
would lead to development
of proper photoreceptors that means the
phenotype that happened
due to the absence of several less is
now rescued
when grb2 is overexpressed and this is
how
they figured out which of the genes are
important for this map kinase signaling
pathway
another gene which was discovered like
this was rash
it turns out that constitutive active
format of ras that means the rash which
is unable to
hydrolyze its gtp which is always active
when you have that kind of mutation in a
sevenless background
it rescues the phenotype because
normally 7 less mutation would
lead to a defect in the eye
development right but over expressing
rash
or this particular mutation would
actually rescue the phenotype suggesting
rash is also a component which is acting
downstream to this particular 7 less
receptor and this is how year after year
analysis
with sophisticated genetic tools and
clear cut thought
scientists had totally figured out
how the map kinase signaling pathway
would look like now this is only the
geneticist
approach throughout the year there are
structural biological
approach there are biochemical approach
which
in addition to this genetic study give
us a holistic idea about the map kinase
signaling pathway
so this video not only describes the
power of genetic
tools to study a signaling pathway but
also tell you an interesting story about
how the mapkins signaling pathway
components were discovered actually
right so i hope you enjoyed this video
if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up and don't
forget to like share and subscribe
and do let me know in the comment how
you like my videos thank you guys